économie environnement énergie
eau social
le développement durable à la Réunion
c'est maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle Carla je suis codée
du collège Jean d'Este et je vais vous
présenter une scène de solidarité dans
une classe les élèves vous avez vu le
problème au tableau vous avez 20 minutes
pour le résoudre et dans le calme s'il
vous plaît allez au travail
respectez la charte de bonne conduite
chuchoter et ceux qui ont terminé aidé
les autres
ça ne sert à rien d'être égoïste et des
autres et il vous aideront
comme le montre ce drapeau qui flotte à
l'entrée du collège depuis juin 2009 le
collège Jean d'Aves et labellisé
éco-école au collège Jean d'Este nous
incitons chacun à adopter des éco-gestes
pour qu'il y ait plus de solidarité
entre nous pour améliorer notre cadre de
vie et pour respecter l'environnement
je peux économiser jusqu'à 140 euros sur
mes factures EDF comment j'éteins les
lumières en quittant la pièce ainsi que
l'ordinateur la radio la chaîne et le
téléviseur en ceci ne sont pas utilisés
j'arrèrent les pièces en faisant des
courants d'air le matin et on était je
ferme les volets ou je tire les rideaux
alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est d'augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le Conseil Général agit
pour le développement durable et vous
économie environnement énergie eau
social
le développement durable à la Réunion
c'est maintenant